so who would you be most worried about
fighting a general election was she sue
neck or lost trust neither of them
they've both been stooges in boris
johnson's government they've both voted
for the tax hikes that people have seen
they both created this cost of living
crisis and propped up a prime minister
that is engulfed in sleaze lies and
partying while people are in lockdown so
i would relish the thought of going
head-to-head with either one of them i
think they're both just as complicit
this is the same continuation of what
has happened in downing street and
what's been happening with this
government for a long time now and it
shows they've got no new ideas and
they've not got the future of the
country at hand well i guess you know
rishi sunak would say that he resigned
from boris johnson's government liz
trust would say that she's promising a
different economic policy it's not
completely continuous continuity boris
isn't it well it'll be interesting to
see how they try and move away from that
over the summer but you know ushi sunak
was the chancellor who did put the tax
heights up and liz trust did support it
and did vote for it at the time and you
know she did stay in the government for
a very long time knowing full well he
was in number 11. in fact my part his
neighbours were having a party i think
i'd have known about it in fact he was
fined himself for a fixed penalty notice
i think they're both just as disastrous
and there is continuation of the same
old maybe not boris johnson but the same
old conservative party and what they've
been trying to get away with so you say
you wouldn't be frightened about
fighting either of them an election you
told rbc that boris johnson had a magic
where he was able to get through to the
public so do you think he was more of an
electoral threat for labour than i was
released to well he clearly was because
in 2019 you know labour suffered a
significant defeat and that was because
boris johnson promised the electorate
something and he did have something that
the electorate connected to do you think
they probably have something in the
electorate no and this is the problem
the problem what boris johnson did is he
broke that trust with the electorate
after getting that 80 seat majority
broke the trust the two now propped him
up after the public had seen that boris
johnson had squandered that victory that
he had lied to the british public put
taxes up not dealt with the issues that
they're facing at the moment with the
cost of living crisis and the two
contenders now we're part of that
government and they don't have that
connection with the public i don't
believe and i think the public have had
enough of the conservative party because
they've seen even in this leadership
contest they've been fighting each other
and trying to distance themselves from
decisions that they've been part of if
they do distance themselves from the
last government promise a new agenda do
you think that actually they have a
mandate to carry it out or do you think
they should re-seek a mandate for an
election i think they should re-seek a
mandate i think the general public are
very angry we saw that with the
by-election results recently the public
are very angry with the conservative
party the problem started with when
boris johnson broke the trust with the
british people and then because of
people like rishi and
liz who propped him up in the cabinet
allowed that to continue the rot to
continue it has now stayed in the whole
of the conservative party so i don't
actually think that they would get a
mandate from the british public now
because they've failed so spectacularly
in doing what the british public asked
them to do whatever happens
the conservative party is either about
to elect the first ever non-white prime
minister or the third female prime
minister all of whom have been
conservative
that's a bit embarrassing for the labour
party isn't it well we will get there
you know we have got our leader at the
moment i'm the deputy i've heard it i'm
the time
i'm the deputy um leader of our party
which means if we get into government
i'll be the deputy prime minister
working class girl from the north same
as the prime minister though is it oh it
matters a lot and it will make a big
difference and i think you know the
labour party come the next leadership
election i'm pretty certain we've got
some magnificent talent in our party and
i think that we'll be able to showcase
that come the next leadership election
but either we didn't fit they mustn't it
well i think the party have done better
than you i think
diversity matters sure diversity matters
in terms of where people are from et
cetera but diversity in terms of ideas
matters as well and at the moment we're
getting the same old policies and the
same old ideas and the same old sleaze
from the conservatives at the moment
they haven't addressed the issues that
people are facing like the cost of
living actually most people will say yes
diversity matters and it's great however
if you're offering the same things and
you're not actually making a difference
to my life in the way i want them to
that matters more and i think we can
show that the labour party has changed
since mainly and care took over and that
we can show that we've got a program
that can get us into government and
change people's lives for the better you
touched a bit about your own background
uh there and you know you grew up in
stockport you were a carer for your mum
you had a baby at 16. you know it is
quite a different path from you know the
sort of well-trodden ppe oxford do you
think that people underestimate you
sometimes in parliament people who have
underestimated
underestimated me all my life if i'm
honest you know and i remember the
stigma that i faced when i was a young
mum at 16 and it still burns now and
that's why i'm so passionate about
giving people opportunity and not um you
know some of the rhetoric that we've
heard from conservative ministers around
will just work a little bit harder the
problem with you being on low pays you
just need to get a better job actually i
find that quite offensive because when i
was a low paid worker i was a casual
worker zero hour contract care worker
and i was a young mum i struggled then
and it was nowhere near as bad as the
cost of living for those people today
and it's not about them not wanting to
work harder i think it's the
conservative party are really out of
touch with how people are really
struggling today people in work are
really struggling and are frightened
about what's going to happen come
october when it's winter and their bills
go up again and their cost of living and
their food prices are going up people
are really struggling and not hearing
from the conservatives what they're
going to do to challenge that what kind
of stigma you mentioned in the stigma
that you faced oh it's just like oh she
speaks with an access accent she must be
thick i'll probably get that again after
being on your show unfortunately
i'm working class so therefore you know
we're not as good if you know if a posh
guy from a private school walks in a
room he automatically gains respect oh
he's got a status if i walk in a room i
have to earn the respect because people
look at me and look at me differently
and and that's how society is
unfortunately it's not unique for me
many women and many working class people
face those challenges as well many
people from uh you know many people of
color face the same level of
discrimination as well and it is a
product of society unfortunately and
we've got to change that that's why i
won't change the way i speak that's why
i talk about my background is because we
can do better and actually the general
public when they see more of that and
they see people in positions of power
being making a difference and really
holding their own then it changes that
perception i was quite struck when you
went toe to toe with donut rob recently
at deputy prime minister's questions and
he said she talks about working people
where was the right honourable lady when
the comrades were on the picket line
last thursday she was at the glenborn
music festival sipping champagne and
listening to opera
do you think that's a kind of snobbery
in itself well it is a snobbery in
itself actually you know i've always
fought for workers all my life and
everyone knows that my record is very
clear on that and i think the government
have really failed to tackle some of the
issues they're in power and have really
failed to tackle the issues that we face
at the moment with endemic low pay for
workers of course they're angry and they
have my full support with that but the
idea that a working-class person can't
go to the opera when actually i was
there to visit a working-class
friend of mine who plays violin at the
opera and has played violin there for 36
years and was proud to be there i think
that shows how out of touch is actually
working-class people can enjoy opera and
should be able to go there and in fact
the tickets to go to the opera were a
lot cheaper than the tickets to go to
glastonbury but hey i wonder whether i'd
have got the same stigma if i'd have
been seen raving at glastonbury um
briefly on that same uh outing
dominic rob winked right i think he
actually might better show the um
the photo of him winking uh now he i
asked him about this i asked him about
this he said he wasn't winking at you he
was winking in mung murray do you
believe him i think he was winking at
himself i think he thought he did a
really good job it was really weird me
and rachel looked to each other and said
that was weird it was just a very weird
thing to do
and just finally now i know i'm going to
ask this question you're going to be
studiously lord kirsten you're going to
say that he is the person you want to
see as the next prime minister so we can
just take that as a given
but do you think you've got what it
takes to be prime minister oh do you
know i say this all the time when
originally i used to think there's no
way that i could be prime minister of
this country you know that the fact that
i got into parliament it's such an honor
to represent my constituency of fashion
online but since boris johnson has done
it i thought he set the bar so low that
i actually think even terry from the
local pub could do a better job than
what boris johnson has done but actually
we need standards in public life
what's the answer then yes i think i
could do it now i think i could and
actually i think it's really important
that um kids from my background do have
that aspiration and think you know what
you can do it and i was guilty of
thinking i couldn't do it because for
all of the reasons i think there's
always someone better than myself and
actually i think on your show speaking
to people from my background i should
say you could do whatever you want would
you put your mind to it quite like fancy
it i think it would be really done and
you know if i can't go to the opera then
god help me if i became prime minister
okay thank you uh very much angela
rainer